[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker former nfl lineman
and ross tucker football podcast also
working westwood one
as the nfl analyst we invite you to hear
more from uh
ross tucker on his ross tucker football
podcast
coming up let's see you got you got
army navy next weekend you got
a game uh this week do you got
pittsburgh
what game do you have this week so i've
got
dan i've got tomorrow night cowboys
ravens oh okay
one then army navy then sunday
i'll do bills and the steelers so i know
you pay attention to this stuff dan
that means i will have called games this
year either nfl
or fbs division one football monday
afternoon
monday night tuesday night wednesday
night thursday night
saturday sunday so the only thing i'm
missing for setting i believe an
all-time nfl division one football
analyst record is friday night so
somehow in the next couple weeks
i got gotta figure out a way to get a
friday night game in no just do a high
school game
you know the irony is i do this
pennsylvania state championship games
every year
but because of the covid pandemic
they were thanksgiving weekend which is
when i was doing the university of
buffalo game
where jared patterson was one carry away
dan
from breaking the all-time rushing
record and touchdown records
and i don't know if you saw but i did
not take it overly well when he was
pulled from the game
he is uh ross tucker joining us on the
program all right now
just give me the defensive philosophy of
greg williams
like what what is he thinking in this
moment as to why this is going to work
given putting pressure on derek carr
and leaving his secondary exposed and in
this situation with henry ruggs man on
man coverage
yes i don't think it's necessarily the
smartest move but i will tell you
dan this is who he is i mean he almost
always
is going to be more aggressive than the
situation would typically call for
i played for him in buffalo in 2003
washington in 2007 when he was a
defensive coordinator
this is kind of who he is the thought
process by the way i'm not saying that's
right
the thought process is if you come with
a zero blitz right that means you're
bringing one more guy then the offense
has the block
the quarterback has to get rid of the
ball
before he can throw it deep and all you
need to do is have your defensive backs
or man-to-man coverage
play off coverage so if they're playing
off they're given a 10-yard cushion
quarterback needs to get rid of it he's
got to throw it underneath or get rid of
it quickly
you come up and you make the tackle
unfortunately the jets
undrafted free agent corner lamar
jackson
didn't really get the memo and he fall
he fell for a
double move a stutter and go which yeah
you cannot do that i mean you can't do
that so i know a lot of blame is going
to greg williams
and that's fine but if you're lamar
jackson in that situation
there is no double move buddy just you
play back you let him catch you in front
of you and then you tackle him
that's what i didn't understand okay
greg williams puts pressure on the
quarterback but greg williams
as as much as we can say well that's who
he is
i got to take care of my secondary
that's going to be exposed
and i got a rookie on henry ruggs who's
one of the top
five fastest players in the game and he
bites on a double move like
if i gather that defensive my secondary
i said guys
everything's in front of you
everything's in front of you we're going
to blitz
everything's in front of you make make
them catch the ball in the middle of the
field
that's it and then if you want to send
six guys
okay but i just i don't that's what i
don't understand
i would fire greg williams for not
telling his secondary
don't let anybody get behind you
well i i don't know how do we know that
he didn't tell him that
but ultimately i would say dan it's his
responsibility
you know like whether lamar jackson and
not the quarterback lamar jackson the
jets db lamar jackson
what you know no matter whether he knew
the situation or not
it's ultimately the coach's job to make
sure
that your young player does not make
that mistake i mean
but that's the thing coaches i think
sometimes take
situational awareness for granted like
okay this guy knows play off
you don't you don't get beat on a double
move a stutter go i mean
i still can't believe it happened i'd
like to think that all the danettes you
me that we would have been like 20 yards
off okay
catch it underneath we'll come and
tackle you but lamar jackson he got the
distance
closed on him he fell for it and he got
beat very very badly
was yesterday a good day for the jets
absolutely okay yesterday was a great
day for the jets
because it showed some promise without
losing the ability at the number one
overall pick i got to tell you
the i haven't had that much fun in a
while dan watching the red zone the end
of the one o'clock games and look there
was a bunch of great games the lions
bears ending the texans fumble against
the colts
but just watching the jags and the jets
and the trevor lawrence sweepstakes
drama
and what makes it so amazing to me is
adam gase and doug marone
they know they're gone they know they're
getting fired after the year
so they have no incentive to uh feather
the nest for the next head coach like
what
how does it help them if the next head
coach gets the number one pick against
trevor lawrence
and has success there so these guys are
out there
trying to win a game to screw over the
next head coach
who's gonna take over for them after the
season it's amazing well sam darnold
probably tried to sabotage this as well
because if they win a couple of games
all of a sudden they go
all right maybe we don't need a
quarterback here we're talking to ross
tucker the former nfl offensive lineman
his podcast ross tucker football podcast
what would you do if you're doug
peterson at the quarterbacking position
i would go with jalen hurts and i would
go with jalen hurts for a couple reasons
number one
he actually showed a spark he made some
good throws they moved the ball
on a couple drives in a row including
the touchdown drive
and not only that dan it's been painful
to watch carson wentz
painful and i say that from a couple
different standpoints number one
he was so good in 2017 he was even so
good the end of the year last year
when he led them on that run to win the
division with a bunch of practice squad
guys
to watch what he's become this year it's
it's not quite that bad dan but it's
almost like
when a baseball player has the yips like
he just won't
pull the trigger he is looking at the
rush he's looking down
he he just he needs to be rebooted
mentally and so
i start hurts if hertz plays great
awesome
play him the rest of the year if hertz
is terrible
then maybe you consider the week after
putting wence back in
but they got to do something to try to
reset
unplug whatever you want to say with
wentz
because he is i've never seen anything
like this a quarterback
deteriorate their performance this bad
and he's such a good young man
he just became a new dad it's honestly
like painful to i watch every snap i do
eagles pregame and preseason tv
it's painful to watch when you know how
good of a kid he is and how much he
wants it
to see how badly he's playing and how
much
he says he hasn't lost his confidence he
refuses to pull the trigger i mean
he takes sacks that you just can't take
explain to me the chiefs they might be
the best team in football
but they certainly have a knack a bad
habit of keeping
everybody that they're playing in the
game doesn't matter dan you don't you
don't check twitter enough chiefs are
clearly the best team in the history of
the galaxy
they're going to win every playoff game
by 20. they're way better than the
steelers
it's it you know it really is emblematic
of our society
we all know mahomes is great and tyra
kale and travis kelsey look
and the chiefs are great and they might
win it again but there's this narrative
out there
that the steelers quote-unquote aren't
really good
because they haven't looked that
impressive in some of their
wins meanwhile you know the chiefs just
barely beat the broncos the week before
that they beat the bucks by three week
before that raiders by four in a great
game the week before that
they beat the panthers the panthers by
two
like there's this thought process out
there that the chiefs are some
unbeatable team
it's just not based in reality i think
that chief steelers game
will be awesome i hope it happens but
this idea that the chiefs are like 20
points better
it's just not found in any sort of
reality
are the browns good or very good
that's a great question i'm gonna say
good i think the
chiefs and steelers are very good i
think
the browns and bills are good i'm not
gonna i can't go very good
with with the browns or the bills i will
say this though i love what the browns
did yesterday
my favorite thing is when teams shatter
the lazy narrative about him like last
week
dan i tweeted that kevin stefanski
should be
in the running for coach of the year
because he has the cleveland browns at
8-3
and you know who replied to me some guy
named mclovin
andrew perloff and said yeah but who
have they played
who have they played you know they
played mclovin they've now played 12
nfl teams they've won nine of the games
including beating the
brains off the titans they beat the
colts this whole schedule thing with the
brown
they're the browns it's that we're
talking about the cleveland
browns and they're nine and three and
you've got
back row bumbling whatevers like mclovin
saying but who have they played though
who have they even played
i'm still mad at him about that yeah but
why do you let it bother you
it's mclovin like you're better than
that
i know i you're right you're right
you're right i just i don't i like
getting fired up i
i miss you guys i haven't been up there
in a while and so when mclovin
and everybody's like yeah who have they
played oh that it helps when you play
the nfc
this whole like this isn't college
football like
you play who's on your nfl schedule and
they beat
nine nfl teams all right let me let me
let
mick lovin this is ivy league on ivy
league crime yeah mcleod
i mean ross honestly i follow you for
the press box food recommendations i
just saw an actual football tweet so i
felt like the need to respond
instead of the fact that they had a
chicken marsala at the
colorado state press room so i was so
taken aback by this
oh you know mclovin you mock what you
don't understand
okay those press box food videos
get terrific engagement people love it
and maybe if you're ever actually in a
press box
you would be able to enjoy how delicious
it is and by the way i'm also matt
you got you get meat friday mclovin you
can just be quiet with the meat friday
traeger grills so good
i saw what allen put out for you guys
friday i wanted to kill somebody i
wanted to eat that so bad
was dartmouth your safe school
didn't really consider it i was only
looking at like real ivy league schools
like
harvard yale and princeton i mean if
you're gonna go ivy league dan
why would you go to like a second rate
second tier one you know what i mean
like i agree and that's why harvard you
are princess
that's why i didn't go i because i it
was just the secondary ivy league
schools
i didn't get the elite ones uh i'll
leave you with this
washington and pittsburgh buffalo and
san francisco
uh any surprises do you see an upset
can washington beat the steelers yeah i
think they can
i don't think they will but i actually
think both these games are going to be
awesome football games today
because the steelers are coming in this
one they're limping a little bit
no james connor they just played
wednesday
washington's playing better washington
hasn't played in 11 days
pittsburgh played five days ago i think
washington has a real chance
to win this game and i think tonight
bill's niners
from arizona will be very entertaining
we got a great monday on tap
did you ever have a good experience when
you played in washington
uh yes i did because we were and five
my rookie year and then we won our next
five and marty shot number i think i had
i had nine head coaches dan
uh in seven years do the math on that
one marty schottenheimer
was awesome i love that guy i love that
team
we won five in a row after we started
out oh and five so yeah that was
actually a great experience
and washington would have been so far
ahead of things
but then daniel snyder fired him after
one year
because marty wouldn't let daniel snyder
make the decisions with the front office
so he got fired after one year brought
in spurrier
easily the worst coach i ever had so
arguably the best coach i ever had to
the worst
just because daniel snyder wanted to
call the shots it's really a shame
why was spurrier so bad
uh didn't put the time in didn't
understand
protections at the nfl level we we had
two
i mean i remember playing i started
every preseason game for him in o2
we had two protections dan and there
were no hot reads no sight adjusts
so you're just supposed to audible to
the other protection or to a different
play
based on what the defense is showing
well in the nfl if they show the guys
are coming from the left
they're coming from the right i mean it
was i could i mean i could do a whole
segment on spurrier he was not a good
coach but we kind of liked him
because if it rained we wouldn't have
practice because he didn't want to stand
in the rain
so we used to root for rain just so we'd
have to practice that day
did he know your name because he
famously did not know the names
of his players especially on defense oh
no he knew my name
because um one time in a team meeting
i got pushed back against the steelers i
gave up like
four yards to casey hampton and uh in
the team meeting spurrier said
hey tucker uh this uh
these aren't like those guys from yale
or brown
these guys mean business up here you're
getting pushed back
meanwhile dan casey hampton's like the
strongest dude in the history of the
world i was actually pretty happy that i
only gave up four yards of push on the
play
but everybody all the guys are dying
laughing
and i just i was kind of over the ivy
league thing at that point so i didn't i
didn't take it very well and he came up
to me at the practice is like
you mad at me i'm like no i'm not mad at
you but like it's my second year now can
we get past the ivy league thing like
i'm here now
like so anyway you poor guy
being held back by going to princeton
man i really feel
bad for you it's uh it's something i've
had to try to overcome my entire
professional career
uh it's always great to talk to you safe
travels there buddy we appreciate it as
always thank you ross
all right see you dudes ross tucker the
ross tucker football podcast listen
you might learn something